300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hassana counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah subhanahu wa tala's book like
you've never had before
assalamu alaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
i'm here in stamford deal stanford here
was not somewhere far from where i used
to live near seven sisters nearly all my
life i drive past here many times before
islam and when i didn't come to islam as
well um and i'm here with rabbi uh rabbi
can i have your name rabbi herschel look
obe okay rabbi herschel look glock obi
okay what can i call you in short so
sure sure okay that'll be make my life
really easy yeah uh so i'm i'm thank you
for coming firstly rabbi it's it's it's
no it's i wanted to come last week but i
was doing a little bit of a tour with um
a tv tv station museum tv station uh and
i couldn't buy as soon as i got here i
wanted to cover this and nice to see you
yeah thank you very much and you know i
didn't have a cameraman but we've got
aaron
doing the camera work so rabbi um jokes
aside obviously i would love to come
here and spend more time and have jokes
but something serious happened here
and we saw on the um here on the board
that it's even asking for witnesses now
a camera opposite that i'm assuming is
that a synagogue is
so the synagogue camera caught
a uh a a a elderly man
walking past here so what happened to
him so he was walking just minding
zombies on the way to synagogue
and
this
20-something muslim
person dressed with muslim clothes
came up to him
and
hit him strongly with the bottle
and the frozen
water bottle and the force was so strong
that he fell down
hit his head against the wall yeah so he
he was he was here walking
so he was walking
hit his head yeah passed out yeah broke
his foot yeah
and didn't know what happened
and is this the just one attack that
happened no there were five attacks five
attacks five attacks the same day by the
same individual to all jewish people
only jewish people he didn't
discriminate only attacked jews okay so
it's it's it's very clear his motives
are very clear
we can't say this was you know this is
very clear he only attacked jews yeah
and
totally unprovoked people just minding
their own business going about their own
things going to synagogue
doing
uh their own personal matters and this
guy just came up to them out of the blue
and attacked them now we've got some
footages and we've got some pictures of
this individual uh well he has been
caught rabbi when was he what was he
caught yesterday yesterday in west
yorkshire in west yorkshire so he lives
up there or he ran up there yeah he
lives up there he's from up there yep
okay all right so brothers and sisters
you know the prophet this reminds me of
the prophet peace be upon him said he
said the lowest form of iman faith is to
move harmful things in the road so if
i'm walking down the road and i see a
hazard and i think you know be the
jewish community or people in general
might trip over it it's my duty as a
muslim to move that from the road so it
causes no harm
now let alone me moving objects when a
person who's a muslim who's dressed up
in a though comes to a jewish area let
alone moving harm is causing harm to the
people and i don't know what kind of
delusion he's under
i hope he doesn't think that this is
some kind of a reward that he's going to
get from god because he'll be very
deluded because this is very against let
alone humanity you know to target a
group of people who are you know you're
just walking about your business is
disgusting and as the muslim community
you know we suffer this as well you know
so we know how it feels you know i when
i walk down the road or something i have
to look behind me sometimes you know i'm
involved in the dawah especially the
sisters exactly yes
because since they go with hijab
people recognize them and yeah and
sometimes buses don't stop for them
and they they suffer and and i've spoken
out many on many occasions on their
behalf and rabbi um
yeah rabbi you know what it is this
matter here i'll be honest with you even
if no muslims got attacked in the world
i will still cover this it's not i'm not
doing this because it's worse vice versa
it's not about it happened to us the
point here is brothers and sisters this
is a disgusting act how could you attack
an elderly man this is a cowardly number
one yeah attack an elderly man going
about his own business and you hit him
so much that he breaks his ankle and
falls on the floor not only that you
carry on your attacks throughout
attacking five other people i mean we've
got a muslim brother here i don't know
do you know what's happened here yeah um
actually somebody got um attacked here
yes um so it was an assault actually yes
when
somebody was not someone punched
somebody and knocked himself so he was a
muslim brother like he was someone that
was yeah actually it was the bedded man
um yes it was baby do it he had the hat
on and the other phone how do you feel
as someone because you share the same
garment really really really annoyed uh
really upset it really hurts my heart to
see somebody do like this sort of um
attack on on any person obviously and
what's your name brother my name is
youssef
yeah um do you live local no i live in
um i live in east ham
i work in this area with the jewish
community yeah i've been working here
for the last 20 years old friends
[Applause]
i've been working for the community here
um
as a medicare driver for the last 20
years
and i'm
i'm
everyone's
so brothers and sisters
rabbi what other last words would you
give
to you know people out there to be more
vigilant maybe and and how do you feel
like you know i'm sure you know you live
local here you know and you're the head
of um
yes and that is like we know it's jewish
police but
it's it's people who care for their
community for all members of the
community that's all of us whatever the
background the 100 yeah what's it called
okay i'm a muslim showman as well then
you know
okay any last words you'd like to give
to the camera maybe
the way
our communities live together here is
one of harmony it's one of peace it's
one of helping one another and with and
just in a natural way we don't make a
point of it we're just a community of
communities
and it's very sad that someone came
all the way from yorkshire to make
trouble because but on the other hand it
shows that here
we are not making trouble here we're
living in peace and harmony and long
please god may that continue hopefully
and brothers and sisters you know i'm
i'm quite familiar with the stanford
deal community as well i know rabbi beck
i i've been trying to contact recently i
haven't maybe is abroad but like i said
before i'm really interested in your
religion in the sense that for example
how your marriages are conducted and
aaron said he promised me that one day
he will bring me to maybe a wedding just
to experience that and see and he
teaches me a lot of things about a
religion that i don't know myself so
problem says if you want to you know
educate yourself with your ignorance
come speak his corner aaron and his
friend is there many times and i asked
him many questions how does this happen
how does this work you know he was
telling me and in about a couple of
hours it's their sabbath and he came
here and i want to thank him and i'm
sure his shoulders are hurting i'm going
to finish this uh
interview and this video and hopefully
the person the person has been caught i
was doing this video so he can be caught
but he has been caught and hope justice
will be done until next time assalamu
alaikum
thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
he's going to break my hand yes very
strong man thank you very much